hello everybody and welcome to awesome
comics your one-stop shop for everything
come up with entertainment I'm your host
Walter Pineda they were doing a little
something different today we're gonna be
playing the game injustice having a
little tournament here and we're also
gonna be debating a couple of topics
that we really disagree on so we're
gonna see how we go about that the
winner will get to have the Pick of the
Week and we've all brought different
picks of the week here and we're gonna
get to go into detail the winner will at
the end of the episode okay
before I introduce these guys last week
Batgirl versus Robin a lot of people
seem to like the the idea of our versus
episode so keep commenting about what
you want to see us fight about like what
do you want to see you want to see a
character versus a character or a topic
some kind of topic you want to see us
fight about we'd love to do more vs.
episode so keep commenting about that I
saw a lot of really good suggestions in
the comments for the day I want to hear
more I want to hear more keep them
coming I always want to say to like the
Facebook page
that's facebook.com slash awesome comics
show go ahead and like that because
there's always new content going up
there exclusive content like porter's
review of arrow season 4 and the extra
round from Batgirl versus Robin last
week there's an extra round that we had
to cut for time on the main episode and
that is exclusively available on the
Facebook page so go ahead and like that
okay everybody so before we get into
actually playing this game I wanted to
introduce you guys so we'll go to my
left here when you're in the Pikachu
tank tab very nice
looks good how's it going yes are you
excited to play this I am very excited
to play this I always just play with my
future brother-in-law so I'm excited to
see how you all match up well this is
gonna be interesting
it really is Ayanna what's up reppin
Gryffindor today who are you gonna be
using this game oh there's a lot of
different characters a lot of okay I'm
feeling we know at least one of them
okay mr. Brian Porta what's up man howdy
the man doing is generously as ps4 Gary
let's play this and his game Premium
Edition with Ultimate Edition Ultimate
Edition scat all the characters and
skins yeah that little trailer for
injustice - did you guys all see that
yeah yeah man that was pretty good yeah
pretty good I can't wait I love how
their armor all comes up yeah it comes
great I'm there excited to check that
out and play but right now we're gonna
be playing injustice the first game and
what we're gonna be doing is gonna be me
versus Porter Heather versus ion and the
winners will face each other and we're
gonna be debating some topics like I
said that we disagree on so we're gonna
start with me and Porter right now let's
get down to it everybody me vs. Porter
here we go first round we're gonna be
debating so this might be kind of a moot
point right now yeah we've heard but
we're gonna talk about anyway I think
Fox can at least sin I faithfully adapt
a version of old man Logan the comic
book poor is completely against that so
awful just know just know who you got
destro okay
I want to go Deathstroke red Sun skins
oh you know at Green Lantern oh wait you
can choose a Jon Stewart if you want it
yeah that's good
he's and is actually voiced by the
original that's pretty awesome why why
don't you want old man Logan dude what's
wrong with you there's too many Marvel
characters like Marvel Cinematic
Universe characters that Fox doesn't
have the rights to and they're there
have to change everything you're gonna
change the whole frickin movie like it's
gonna be the most heavily edited like
frickin I don't think they're doing it
from what we heard I'm even though he
kind of looks like he's got the beard
and everything yeah but I don't know I
think they could do it I mean if they
just take the the basic premise of it
you know II mean like I think that they
could totally handle it I really don't
think so and you know with all the stuff
that guy got wise professor excellent
you know what I mean like right well
that's completely this what I'm saying
like it's and if you're gonna do old man
Logan you need to do like all the stuff
I mean freaking I want to see a Venom
symbiote right there's a ton of stuff
like a dynasty Oh dinosaur
like that's awesome like spider-woman
and all that and write a character play
Martin you're right that there's a ton
of characters especially Hawkeye's
accused for odd story that Marvel does
not have the rights to or I'm sorry Fox
doesn't have the rights to yeah like
it's no I still think they could do it I
think that if they do it the right way
with the basic premise and the Hulk in
that is the main villain and he's not
even he's not even like the Hulk man
he's an umbrella quit monster guy and
he's not even Bruce Banner for most of
it I mean like you really think like
just putting another like random villain
in there like that has like the same
kind of deal that has like an inbred
weird monster family you'd have to do
like I think or something like that and
that could more have to do blob okay so
what those you need to have reveal at
the end you need that big what happened
it's like reveal you know it's talked
the entire time no you need that like
when he battles them and then frickin
end okay spoilers when he freakin gets
eaten by Hulk that is awesome though and
then he rips them to pieces within the
pieces but you can do that with anybody
the Hulk is not the only person has
flesh and I want to see you Jackman his
old man Wolverine you know I mean hey I
watch it
yeah Bucky I know we're doing best two
out of three I'm gonna go with Captain
Marvel slashes am sorry you don't think
that they could adapt that like why no
because like a basic premise if you just
replace some characters I think they can
do it well let's just let's just do this
one story and then replace everything
that made it good and I have no faith in
the director none absolutely you know
like the the first two Wolverine there
Shea nobody likes the first one but I
mean you don't like even the Wolverine
would something like she's like no it
was awful that was a terrible movie why
why don't you like it um everything the
fact that it was in the the timeline was
terrible the fact that he went to Japan
after he already met them x-men he's
going there because he's upset about
genes death like you son of a bitch
that's terrible
that is absolutely terrible it
completely messes with the mythos of
Wolverine and I just don't think it was
a it was a terrible movie Wolverine your
favorite character I mean he's your
favorite comic-book character not just
Marvel right and he's like your favorite
period yeah he's all know Deadpool I'm
pretty sure
yeah wow that's I just comment count
awesome comic so exclusive there I
thought I thought he would always been
your favorite Oh Dan you know my dad was
a comeback I was good I never did saw
this laugh before
yeah it's awesome oh that's really cool
what else world's flash is this from I'm
not sure it's flash versus green arrow
oh I just slice them you up
slice and dice well I don't know what's
happening you got a weapon I don't
something but anyway I don't think that
it could work at all at all I think it
is a terrible terrible idea and there's
way more stuff that they could do I
think they should do death of Wolverine
I know it's really loose now that would
but that would make sense with that
would make sense yeah that wouldn't make
sense well isn't this called like
Wolverine and Weapon X one incredibly
stupid it is a weird title because we've
already gone back in time I win
looks like I didn't get my ass I can't
believe you beat me in my own game and
you know what's happened before so yeah
well you see I love the flash costume it
looks awful I want to know what what
book that's when I'm gonna read their
book if anyone knows comment what what
costume is that is that from I want to
see it that's crazy I want to read the
book okay well I move on
sorry next we have Ayane and Heather
going up against each other the winner
will face me in the fall what do you
have experience playing this game
Rihanna yes not much no fantastic all
right I don't you don't that's sad I'm
gonna go with the classic Harley Quinn
skin yeah girls wing a name yeah oh you
did pick a different skin oh yes I do
okay so elastic is my favorite why is
the classic your favorite um it's always
what I think of as soon as I think of
Harley Quinn that was our first
introduction to the character is in this
in this costume and as many girls in the
90s you grew up watching Batman the
Animated
and guys yes yes yes but I feel like
especially as a female I always really
liked that her costume was not so like
sexy
it came tight I mean it here front
literally head to toe - like her
fingertips but it's still it's still
sexy and it's still skin tight so I
disagree that it's not sexy I think it's
it's clowny sexy you don't like the news
suicides no not at all I just think it's
way too I always hate to say it's way
too revealing because I feel like people
have the right to wear what they want
oh yeah yeah um but I know a lot of
people would agree with you that it's
you're revealing hey yeah but I disagree
I don't think it's too revealing
um they're going for like a Sid and
Nancy s type of feel with the the new
Suicide Squad with Harley and Joker and
what up and because of them I think if
we're going with the Rockstar route
there's a who's a um Debbie Harry in
blondie she she has like a like a promo
shot where she's basically wearing
Harley's outfit she's got like the belt
the undies and the tee and that's not
the character that's another character
that's Harley Quinn being another
character I know II know Harley Quinn
it's just they're they're they're
updating it what up it's my cat getting
it um but this is far from the first
time that Harley's gotten a makeover
right no and so I like it way better
than Arkham Asylum a oh my gosh I hate
the Arkham Asylum I can agree with you
on that okay so we're talking about
Harlem bar Farge um like don't hate it
as much as I hate Enchantress's outfit I
okay her metal bikini yeah I hate it
with passion
I think she should have had some pants
like fine put her in the metal bikini
top but I leave
pan I don't know pick one that's I
another you know Charlie's calcium I
don't know my grandma always told me
like pick one thing to show off you pick
the cleavage or you click pick like like
their legs or pick one thing and go with
it I always costume does that she should
she's cheeky and he's a little cheek and
that's fine but oh yeah okay and I know
the actress who is playing Margot Robbie
yeah totally nice she totally defends
her cause she does she's bleep she just
wears it cuz it's sparkly right but I
think it's just justification because
like yeah
I can see that justification of like oh
she would pick it for herself cuz it's
sparkly and fun and whatever but then
don't show it objectified in the trailer
you know like when she bends over to get
the purse and looks like I straight up
gives us some room for her to go as a
character though I'm really worried
about though she is like they've changed
her background now and being like she is
like property of the Joker if we're
talking about like being comic-book
accurate it is oh I like that right but
I just don't like the new 52 origin that
they adapted because like it takes away
all of her gosh what is even the word
I'm looking for
like choice like it was totally the joke
choice that she absolutely homes Harley
yeah completely
it's like something for each of
thankfully because they're making her
such a um such a like big role in this
movie like think about the other female
characters they don't seem as big as
like the other male characters and we're
gonna get Harley front and center in
this which is like a fan favorite who
was originally just supposed to be like
a one-shot yeah that's amazing
and so like she's always she's always
been kind of like a debate whether or
not she's treated right and weird right
right and stuff and I think that she
maybe has room to grow you know I mean I
would like to go yeah a little worried
about the dead turn possibly yeah
possibly like having her in the suit
later they said they were great on
though but it didn't work in this world
and I understand that you know like if
she was in this like you know latex or
leather cat suit whatever they ended up
going with you know yeah like maybe it
didn't fit with the whole rock star by
that they're going for in this right you
know I but like I said I have issues
with the whole costuming in general so
maybe that's just maybe that's what the
issue is not necessarily with just
Harley Quinn but with the whole feel and
look of the whole entire movie oh yeah
come right off there we go and looks
like my can't you guys love those shoes
okay do you know oh that's another thing
I hate Harley shoes I have to put my
foot down on that what her stupid like
heels gym shoes I think that's good I
have high heel spiked voices I got when
I lived in Tokyo and I loved them so
much that's another no not a fan they're
really easy to walk in you'd be
surprised she could kick button it she
could exactly dab the butt exactly all
right win doesn't matter I winner
chicken dinner
good game good game
okay it's the finals everybody it's
moving together you know what I'm just
gonna go ahead and win this right away
epic doom day Oh regular doom why do we
fight about Heather
well I know when we talked about best
Marvel movie you were really a big fan
of spider-man and I I love spider-man
spider-man is its Batman spider-man when
I was younger it was like trading off it
was better
come on how do you not like your scene
he's like supposed to be a teenager and
he's not always a team he's not always a
teenager but in general I've never I
just never liked him I thought he was
just kind of obnoxious and like I said
funny
do you like Deadpool no I don't
okay what's your consistent on that
exactly at least I'm consistent on that
um no I
I've always loved spiderman like since I
was a kid like he's so relatable he's
he's great he's got I mean he is funny
when he's in the spider-man suit but he
has like all these like real-world
problems he's very relatable as a as a
young man what you know that's how I win
ironically one of the reasons I started
like Haiti not just straight up not
liking him but hating him was because
the first Sam running movie what yes yes
Heather I did the movie I thought was so
bad it's a comic book movie I'm sorry
feelings day a wind I am bench
spider-man right there thank you
doomsday he's got like I'm stoned braid
that's better than a bone braid oh look
at that destruction as I'm talking about
I can't believe you don't like spine
I thought you as you it's I know you I
knew it why human being I thought you
guys I thought you would like spider-man
oh I just like I thought I even in the
movie I hated how he was just so like
you guys like on nobody you said have
you seen have you ever seen any of the
other spider-man believe I have alright
have you seen all of them I have why do
you keep torturing yourself in hmm
that's the better question because it's
ingrained in pop culture is it not would
you it is but you have to know we don't
have to be a comic book fan you don't
have if you don't like spider-man
then you shouldn't see the movie so I
didn't see spider-man 3 that's well good
good I good I knew on that yeah for sure
I mean I'll see homecoming because I
didn't hate him in Civil War he was
funny but he was just funny that was it
it was just like well he had a very
small part yeah one good part with Tony
Stark though what is like when stuff
happens and you can do what I can do
it's your fault
come on with great power comes ver
responsible for picking one a woman for
this next panel I'm picking Joker but
Taurus Joker which impression is Killing
Joke Joker nope doing it right now
good thing you're not Batgirl okay I
like spider one you like shut up you
like one Stacy um Emma Stone is I think
she's great in those moves he was the
only thing that was good about it I
thought I thought when all else failed
like in the second movie some stuff was
pretty bad at least like her and Andrew
Garfield's chemistry was always great I
thought I thought I was great she is
Oh what I would say spider-man's real
love I would not put Mary Jane as
spider-man's like other half dad that's
a good debate to like I I really like
Mary Jane but I mean I understand why
people like when I just feel like yeah
the tragic story had with gwen stacy was
just so much better
I just and even with the movies like the
chemistry was always so much better what
the movie that I agree that Emma Stone
and
and what's Andrew Garfield we've had
better chemistry until McGuire and
kirsten dunst but right but I like in
general I still like the first
spider-man movie the best with this
first Raimi one the one you think is
corny but I still I still like the
Mannix why am I even made Explorer 9 - I
like I I don't I don't hate it like a
lot of people do that means I win that's
fantastic
look I'm gonna light you on fire wait
check this out that's right you don't
see the body between Curtis lit on fire
Joker and doomsday all bad guys win I'm
sorry that's fine I'm sorry all right
not gonna get talked about right here
thank you
I want to talk about this for a while
I'm talking about right now okay Dark
Knight a true Batman story this is
written by Paul Dini who is a huge huge
part of Batman animated series wrote a
lot of those episodes co-created Harley
Quinn like you guys were talking about
earlier Paul Dini is a badass and this
story is so personal in 1993 I think
they were working on Batman mask of the
phantasm at that point and he was going
through some rough stuff in his life at
that point and he was walking home alone
one night and he got jumped by these two
guys and they beat the living crap out
of him he almost died he was very close
to death and at that point and after
that he was very depressed for a long
time for a few months he was just really
down and went through a lot of stuff
internally and he overcame it and he
started to work on mask of the phantasm
again all of his friends helped him pull
out of it but this this story is just so
unique because in in the pages here you
can see that he like Batman's in the
story Joker's in the story but they're
like figments of his imagination they're
how he deals with things so he kind of
sees the characters in front of them and
he'll talk to them sort of and as a
writer you kind of do that sometimes
with characters and he even start talks
about that at the beginning was
life when he's in church he like
daydream as a kid about he saw like
Superman stuff playing in front of him
stuff like that so I really relate to
that personally because that happens in
my head because I'm crazy so I think a
lot writers - I mean you have
conversations with yourself you have
conversations but characters you create
and in this it is just a real true to
life adaptation or portrayal I should
say of what happens in your brain kind
of when that kind of thing happens so
it's just really unique and really
different I want to talk about for a
long time it came out a couple weeks ago
but when I first heard about it I was
like oh that's gotta be great
so check this out it is well worth
purchasing it's available all over the
place now I got the hardcover and it's a
great story please please check it out
when I win a chicken dinner
that's what it's all about but I only
use one special move so actually I was a
little handy anyway yeah this is a lot
of fun you guys want to see more of this
because this I would love to do more
than yeah we do different games
different 40 games maybe a little Super
Smash Bros because that's my game I'm
gonna thank you oh really we can play
the combat mobile combat Mortal Kombat
would be fun yeah any suggest some games
you guys want us to play I think
there'll be a lot of fun to do but okay
um next week we're gonna be doing a
special fourth of July episode not that
special but it's special to us it's
gonna be Superman doomsday the animated
DC movie so that we're gonna be starting
to cover more of those so suggest what
else you want us to cover for DC
animated movies there's a lot out there
so give us more suggestions on that okay
everybody social media is for everybody
let's go with Porter what do you get
what's gonna say facebook.com slash
awesome port or awesome Porter yeah not
so awesome Keanu yes Twitter I talked to
a lot of you on Twitter it's a lot of
fun hearing what you guys have to think
about stuff I always love that and then
I'm also on Facebook as well I don't
post as much on there recently but start
doing one
come on keep up with ourselves me easy
bad anyway have the roost or Instagram
at a truce excellent runner up today
yeah bad second-place first loser what
I've done yeah it's pretty good number
two no she's she's number two you that's
true maybe we'll do a bout with their
place Amanda but okay until next week
I'm also amazing like these guys are a
bunch of badasses and we will see you on
the next page but watch their watch read
this we watch the pictures and read it
your word